tik tok soll in den USA verboten werden
das wollen ziemlich viele amerikanische
Politiker jetzt haben sie den
tiktok-besitzern sogar ein Ultimatum
gestellt entweder ihr verkaufte us-teil
von tiktok oder wir verbieten euch im
ganzen Land die EU hat ihren
Abgeordneten die App bereits verboten
genauso wie Neuseeland auch in Kanada
Belgien Dänemark und weiteren Ländern
gibt es teilverbote in Indien ist tiktok
ganz gebannt ihre Sorge tiktok könnte
die Öffentlichkeit manipulieren und
China die Möglichkeit geben seine Nutzer
auszuspionieren stimmt das ist tiktok
wirklich so gefährlich und sollten wir
die App sogar hier in Deutschland
verbieten wir haben geguckt was an den
Vorwürfen wirklich dran ist und deutlich
mehr gefunden als uns lieb ist warum die
App gefährlicher ist als viele denken
dass erfahrt ihr jetzt wer ist Tag
[Musik]
die Flut an Nachrichten momentan ist
krass der Präsident der USA lässt die
Datensicherheit von ausländischen Apps
untersuchen und bei zu wenig Schutz
verbieten 19 von 50 Bundesstaaten haben
tiktok bereits auf dienstgeräten von
Behörden verboten Abgeordnete des
Repräsentantenhauses der USA dürfen die
App nun auch nicht nur auf ihren
dienstlichen Geräten verwenden und der
Staat Indianer verklagt sogar den
Mutterkonzern von tiktok weit Dance auf
Unterlassung Schadensersatz und
Bußgeldzahlungen die Spinnen die Amis
oder hinter diesen ganzen Geschichten
rund um tiktok stecken drei ganz
konkrete Befürchtungen die erste ist
Zensur auf der Plattform und damit dann
auch eine Beeinflussung und Steuerung
der öffentlichen Meinung in den USA denn
unsere Meinung können wir nur aus den
Informationen bilden die wir haben wer
also bestimmt was die Menschen wissen
und was nicht der kontrolliert auch was
für eine Meinung sie sich bilden können
wenn man zum Beispiel ganz viele Posts
von Giraffen Attacken auf Menschen sieht
denkt man vielleicht Giraffen sein
gefährlich wenn man hingegen viele
niedliche Post von Giraffen Babys sieht
dann denkt man sie sein die süßesten
Tiere auf der ganzen Welt
die zweite Befürchtung ist dass der
Staat China mit Hilfe von tiktok Daten
über seine Nutzer sammelt das können zum
Beispiel der Aufenthaltsort Kontakte
suchverläufe oder der Kalender sein mit
Hilfe dieser Daten könnte China die
tiktoknutzer ausspionieren sogar
erpressen oder tun was Geheimdienste
ebenso tun an dieser Stelle bleibt das
alles ein bisschen vage und die dritte
Befürchtung einiger Politiker ist eine
Verdummung der Bevölkerung ein bisschen
wie das römische brot und Spiele solange
die Menschen unterhalten sind
protestieren sie nicht so der Gedanke
okay was ist dann all diesen Vermutungen
und Vorwürfen dran wir haben
recherchiert und zum letzten muss ich
jeder seine eigene Meinung bilden aber
zu den ersten beiden Vorwürfen haben wir
deutlich mehr gefunden als wir erwartet
hätten also hier sind die Dinge die
dafür sprechen dass die Sorgen der
Amerikaner berechtigt sind und tiktok
vielleicht verboten werden sollte
das eine Social Media Plattform durch
Algorithmen die Inhalte filtert und
bestimmten Nutzergruppen bestimmte
Inhalte zeigt haben amerikanisch
Unternehmen bereits perfektioniert das
ist wohl kaum etwas Neues facebook macht
das Instagram macht das und sogar hier
auf Youtube entscheidet der Algorithmus
was euch angezeigt wird es sind aber
Auszüge aus den moderationsregeln von
tiktok bekannt also nach welchen
Kriterien die Mitarbeiter Inhalte
klassifizieren
netzpolitik.org hat laut eigener Aussage
2019 exklusiven Einblick in diese Regeln
bekommen und die verschiedenen
Kategorien gesichtet bei drei davon gibt
tiktok zu dass sie existieren Löschung
nur sichtbar für den Creator und Risiko
bei Risiko wird der Inhalt vielleicht in
bestimmten Regionen geblockt warum das
hochbrand ist dazu kommen wir gleich
machen wir erstmal weiter mit den
Kategorien die tiktok nicht offiziell
bestätigt hat General für alles was in
keine Sonderkategorie fällt und Features
für Inhalte die tiktok besonders pushen
möchte und dann gibt es gegebenenfalls
noch not for Feed hier bleiben die
Inhalte normal sichtbar ihre Verbreitung
wird aber vom Algorithmus gedrosselt
jetzt ist aber die super interessante
Frage was wird gepusht und was
gedrosselt das Label risk free DOT4
markiert zum Beispiel Inhalte die sich
mit der sexuellen Orientierung
beschäftigen und führt zu einem
geoblocking in islamisch orientierten
Ländern laut tiktok soll mit solchen
geoblockings regionale Gesetze
eingehalten werden naja Freiheit fördern
tun sie auf jeden Fall nicht außerdem
wurden auf tiktok Videos mit
übergewichtigen Menschen gedrosselt das
ist ebenfalls diskriminierend übrigens
Quellen zu allem was wir hier erzählen
findet ihr wie immer in der
Videobeschreibung unter den Nummern die
hier eingeblendet werden auch wenn man
dazu sagen muss das ist kein reines
tiktok Problem Instagram ignoriert seit
Jahren beharrlich dass bei ihnen
ebenfalls Bilder von übergewichtigen
Menschen benachteiligt werden ob jetzt
mit Absicht oder als Nebeneffekt von
anderen Algorithmen das ist unklar
was mehrere Redaktionen auch getestet
haben sind politische Themen zu den
Protesten in Hongkong gibt es
beispielsweise trotz gezielter suche
verdächtig wenig auf tiktok zu finden
die Washington Post stieß auf selfies
Essens Fotos und Single longs während
Twitter zeitgleich vor lauter
protestvideos explodierte
seltsam inwieweit China versucht über
diesen Weg gezielt die Öffentlichkeit zu
manipulieren können wir natürlich nicht
sagen bzw mehr oder weniger alles Social
Media Plattformen verdienen ihr Geld
damit ihren manipulationseinfluss auf
uns Nutzer an Dritte zu verkaufen was
dahinter der Bühne alles abgeht dazu
kommt hier auf Dr Watson übrigens bald
ein richtig großes Video von uns lohnt
sich also zu abonnieren ob China mit
diesen Manipulationsmöglichkeiten auch
eine politische Agenda verfolgt das
lässt sich aber nicht sagen
[Musik]
ein bisschen weiter ist die
indizienliste zur Frage ob China die
tiktok Daten der Nutzer aussperrt dafür
muss man sich erst noch einmal die
Konzernstruktur in Erinnerung rufen
tiktok ist ein Teil der Firma bei Dance
welche wiederum in China sitzt damit
fällt bald Dance unter chinesisches
Recht und damit auch unter zwei Gesetze
die den Datenschützern Sorgen machen das
eine ist das data security love von 2021
das besagt dass ein Unternehmen die
Daten die es in China erhebt auch in
China speichern muss und dass diese
Daten nicht ohne Einverständnis der
Regierung ins Ausland gegeben werden
dürfen das zweite Gesetz ist noch
krasser das National intelligence von
2017 verpflichtet alle Unternehmen und
chinesischen Bürger mit den chinesischen
Geheimdiensten zusammenzuarbeiten und
sie zu unterstützen die Daten von
US-Bürgern fallen aber tatsächlich nur
zum Teil unter diese Gesetze denn im
Allgemeinen gilt digitale Daten fallen
unter die Gesetze des Landes auf dessen
Gebiet die speichern in Server stehen
das wären im Fall von amerikanischen
tiktok dann tatsächlich überwiegend die
USA europäische Nutzerdaten liegen
soweit wir wissen mindestens auf Servern
in den USA und Singapur tiktok will sie
angeblich aber Stück für Stück auf
Server in Irland umziehen das wäre für
uns eine gute Nachricht denn damit
würden sie unter die europäischen
Datenschutzbestimmungen fallen ob tiktok
sich dann daran hält das wird derzeit in
Irland ermittelt also ende gut alles gut
leider nein denn ein wichtiger Punkt
bleibt es ist nach wie vor unklar wann
und wie umfassend Mitarbeiter in China
Zugriff auf diese im Ausland
gespeicherten Daten haben scheinbar weiß
nicht mal tiktok selber das zumindest
laut einigen geliebten Dateien warte was
2022 erschien diese Artikel hier bei
buzzfeed News darin ging es um 80
geliebte Audio Mitschnitte von Meetings
bei tiktok bei denen die Sicherheit von
US-Daten besprochen wurde denn tiktok
arbeitet gerade gemeinsam mit den
US-Behörden an Regeln die die Sicherheit
von zentralen Daten gewährleisten sollen
die Zitate die wir aus diesen
Mitschnitten gesehen haben
klingen für uns so als ob die
Algorithmen und Programme von tik tok
extrem komplex sind so komplex dass
selbst die tik tok Mitarbeiter Probleme
haben herauszufinden wann wer wo über
welche Schnittstelle auf welche Daten
zugreifen kann wenn ihr ein bisschen
mehr über diese Mitschnitte wissen wollt
empfehle ich euch auf jeden Fall diese
Quelle hier in der EU habt ihr übrigens
alle mit dem einverstanden Button unter
der Datenschutzerklärung von tik tok
zugestimmt dass chinesische Mitarbeiter
auf alle eure Daten zugreifen dürfen
aber das wisst Ihr natürlich die habt
ihr ja alle gelesen aber jetzt kommt der
eigentliche Hammer nach der
Veröffentlichung dieser Audio
Mitschnitte spionierte tiktok die
Journalisten hinter dem league-artikel
aus mutmaßlich versuchte tiktok durch
die IP-Adressen der Journalisten
herauszufinden welcher tiktok
Mitarbeiter zur gleichen Zeit am
gleichen Ort war so könnte tiktok
eingrenzen wer die Audiodateien gelegt
hat
welche Daten sonst noch von den
Journalisten abgegriffen wurden wissen
wir leider nicht aber jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich wer war denn bitte bei tiktok so
blöd frei nach dem Motto mist da hat
jemand aufgedeckt dass wir theoretisch
US-Bürger ausspionieren könnten aber es
weiß keiner ob wir das tatsächlich tun
machen wir das doch direkt mal dann
können Sie es uns eindeutig nachweisen
laut tiktok bedauerliche Einzelfälle
mittlerweile hat der CEO von tiktok
offiziell bestätigt dass chinesische
Mitarbeiter aktuell auf Nutzerdaten von
US-Bürgern zugreifen können nach bereits
geplanten Umstrukturierungen in
Zusammenarbeit mit den amerikanischen
Behörden soll das aber nicht mehr gehen
[Musik]
also fassen wir das alles mal zusammen
ob China über tiktok im großen Stil
unser aller Daten abgreift das wissen
wir natürlich nicht die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist allerdings hoch
dass sie es könnten und zumindest in
Einzelfällen auch schon getan haben
bezüglich der Inhalte auf der Plattform
können wir sagen dass sie gezielt
gesteuert werden ob sie das im Sinne
einer politischen Agenda tun wissen wir
ebenfalls nicht im Indien ist die App
bereits verboten in Deutschland sieht es
derzeit nicht danach aus die
Verbotsforderungen in den USA werden
wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile
weitergehen und das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt etwas ironisch denn alles was
amerikanischen Politiker tiktok
vorwerfen können und tun amerikanisches
Social Media Unternehmen selber wie
schon erwähnt wir arbeiten gerade an
einem krassen Video dazu wie alle
umfassend selbst uns hier in Deutschland
nachspioniert wird
jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren
dass es einen Unterschied macht ob der
chinesische der amerikanische oder der
deutsche Staat unsere Daten haben könnte
und vielleicht sollte man das auch ich
für meinen Teil werden mir tiktok aber
auf jeden Fall nicht runterladen wie
viel euch das Risiko wert ist das müsst
ihr natürlich selbst entscheiden und das
ist auch so ein bisschen der Knackpunkt
bei der ganzen Diskussion Optik tok in
Deutschland generell verboten werden
sollte die Grundsatzfrage ist wie sehr
lasse ich als Staat meine Bürger
wirklich dumme Entscheidung treffen wie
beim Rauchen das ist definitiv
gesundheitsschädlich der Staat könnte es
verbieten um seine Bürger zu schützen
oder er lässt uns die Freiheit etwas
Schädliches zu tun und genauso ist es
bei tiktok wozu ihr aber auch die
Freiheit habt ist euch die Planet white
App herunterzuladen und damit etwas
Gutes zu tun ich hat euch letzte Woche
ja schon davon erzählt und jetzt ist die
Initiative offiziell gelogen wenn euch
Artenschutz auch am Herzen liegt und dir
wirklich endlich mal was sinnvolles zu
erhaltenes Planeten tun wollt dann
schaut euch gleich mal dieses Video hier
kann da begeben sich Artenschützer auf
die Suche nach Europas größtem
Landsäugetier dem europäischen Bison das
galt eigentlich bereits als ausgestorben
aber er lebt nun ein Comeback was
wirklich mega cool ist denn es spielt
eine super wichtige Rolle für unsere
Ökosysteme Planet wild ist eine neue
Initiative bei der ich auch selbst
involviert bin und der jeder beitreten
kann der selbst etwas für den Schutz des
Planeten tun möchte ihr als Community
finanziert weltweite Pionierarbeit zur
Rettung bedrohter Tierarten dem Erhalt
von Urwäldern und dem Schutz der Ozeane
das Planet wild Team setzt dann jeden
Monat im Namen der Community diese
Missionen um und berichtet darin in
Videos wie diesem hier ab 5 € im Monat
könnt ihr selbst Teil der Community
werden und dann jeden Monat sehen was
wir gemeinsam bewegen können schaut euch
jetzt hier das Video an und unterstützt
Planet wild wenn ihr etwas Gutes für den
Planeten tun wollt wie immer danke fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig